[Musique]
je crois que vous saurez tout
[Rires]
comment ça se passe et les vendanges
dans le village et quand vous étiez
jeune et ça se passait comme toujours
évolué d'école métrage général mais
alors longtemps longtemps il voulait
même des garages des dégâts va peser
type de l'aveyron de la part et beaucoup
buvait et puis plus tard ils évoluent
vers des espagnols alors cela alors dans
une vie hors du coup perd ils se battent
comme des chiens ils se sourient
[Rires]
qu'est ce que vous faisiez vous alors
l'époque et les je faisais pas l'instant
je faisais la cave et le soir je vais
poser comme tout le monde quand elle
avait au moment où l'on trouvait
toujours une demoiselle
[Rires]
[Musique]
tu vois là bas c'est devant des vieux
fille de l'autre côté là bas c'est le
bon état jamais une femme qui va arriver
et puis nous avons ici c'est le bain des
jeunes y avait des jeunes toujours eu ça
comme ça général ans marié deux villages
ami lou qui était de lui il a pris une
femme qu'elle était du bic général on se
connaît tous y aller comme aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui où il ya déjà marié loi nous
rentrer dedans c'est un iconographe vous
à l'e3 cabba et le dimanche quand il va
les opposer aux on s'amusait lieu que
maintenant il y avait un peu plus
ambiant et pourquoi il ya maintenant
pour moi c'est l'orgueil aujourd'hui
se déplace à l'automobile est ça fait
moins de l'ambiance il y avait des jours
où il y avait rien à dire que vous
ouvriez des chevaux des campagnes on
commence avec 7,7 euros
tout le monde avait des chevaux tout le
monde pas c'est à dire que maintenant
tout le monde avoir des tracteurs pour
le monde année c'est une autre paire de
manches je la vis à trangé nissan
prépare
on a toujours parlé les vendanges mais
on m'a dit que c'était trop difficile
pour moi j'y arriverai jamais donc je
voulais pas que les facettes et vous ça
vous plaît habitudes en anglais j'avais
dix ans j'étais petit enfin moi j'aime
bien on oublie tout mais c'est assez
spécial foot alors très bien la
corruption oui elle est bien on rigole
c'est je travaille je suis un petit
propriétaire enfin vieux il est bien il
fait pas comme les autres propriétaires
il vient avec vous ives en danger
discuter choque un peu de nous occuper
de tout le monde
puis ça fait longtemps qu'il fait ce
métier alors nous raconte ce qui faisait
avant à l'époque des vendanges
on s'amusait bien des fois nous allons
couper le raisin puis vient voir ce
n'est pas blessé puis il aime bien le
jeune fille alors
qui sait la petite brune que j'étais
votre grand père nous tiens voilà 6,17
gel de cet âge n'est du tout de suite
c'est vrai je me lève aussi que fait ce
qu'il veut être fait en général
en général je serai petit gars vous avez
la paix joli sourire jolies filles et je
te dise la paix les plus jolies
vendanges lourds de la région le leurs
qualités professionnelles m'intéresse
pas mais ce que je sais que c'est joli
ça c'était indispensable dans les
échoppes en fin d'année prochaine le
problème parce que j'aime ça le vin est
meilleur
pour les vendanges et même s'il vous
plaît à personne vous mettre là et quand
nous sommes arrivés au bout vous avez
très n'allez pas plus loin des spas je
vais passer pour un tortionnaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je compte revenir équipe battue si je
viens voir je sais pas je viens voir ce
matin tu plais ici regarde car j'en ai
fini le matin je pars le chien fertois
la chasse promener dans les bois dans
les vignes est ce que tu veux de plus
[Musique]